i'm going to talk about a failed
supernova explosion which has resulted
in a weird white dwarf heading out into
the depths of space
[Music]
okay so a paper came out on the 20th of
june
so relatively recently here it is sdss
and then the long telephone number that
tells you what the star is the partially
burned remnant of a low mass white dwarf
that underwent thermonuclear ignition
question mark so i think we need to back
up a little bit and talk about so this
is a white dwarf star
uh and it's associated with a particular
type of supernova uh thing called a type
1a supernova
very famous type of supernova because
it's used as a standard candle something
which is the same brightness wherever
you see it so it's used for cosmology
where we can actually use it and figure
out how far things are away from how
bright it appears
the reason why it's a standard candle is
because of the mode the way in which it
explodes and essentially what happens is
you have a white dwarf
which is a very compact star it's held
up only by the pressure of
quantum mechanics effectively the always
the question with the star is why it
doesn't just collapse under its own
gravity when it's burning nuclear
processes in its core that provides the
energy source that keeps it up but the
end of its life that goes away and the
star will collapse and so for example
for a white dwarf it'll collapse right
down to something about the size of the
earth at that point these weird quantum
mechanical effects kick in and stop it
collapsing any further but what can then
happen there is a maximum mass for which
that effect will work thing called the
chandrasekhar mass
and if you keep adding in some way more
and more mass to the start eventually
you're going to approach that mass and
there's a danger that the thing will
collapse further
and actually all sorts of turmoil will
occur within the white dwarf star it'll
become very convective it'll become very
disturbed inside that's the point at
which white dwarf is in danger of
actually exploding
by firing off a whole bunch of new
nuclear thermonuclear processes but in a
very uncontrolled way
and so it will essentially explode like
a bomb
interestingly the the views on this have
changed it used to be thought that when
a star tipped over that magical
chandrasekhar mass that was the point at
which it blew up as a supernova it's now
thought it never quite gets to that mass
but as it approaches that mass as i say
it becomes very disturbed stirs up very
energetic processes can start happening
and something then kicks off these uh
nuclear explosions within it so then the
question is what why would a star be
putting on weight where is its extra
mass coming from
and
in order for that to happen there has to
be another star nearby to kind of donate
the extra mass and so it's probably in
systems where there's a binary you've
got two two stars orbiting each other
and one of them is donating some of its
mass to the white dwarf and so
eventually it reaches to this point
where these runaway nuclear processes
occur and it explodes so sort of
skimming matter from its next-door
neighbor it's sufficiently close to it
it's actually ripping the the mass off
it it's you know it's its pull of
gravity becomes stronger than the pull
of gravity in the star that was holding
onto that mata to start with so it's
literally ripping off the outer layers
of its of its neighboring star and
acquiring them for itself
usually that process is thought to be
sufficiently disruptive that there's
nothing left at the end that the star
just literally blows itself to bits
the interesting case here is that here
there is still a white dwarf left
but it has some weird properties and in
particular when they studied the spectra
of it when they split the light up into
the colours of the rainbow and looked at
the sort of signature of the different
different chemical elements they found
some of those heavier elements that are
made in the supernova explosions so it
looks like some sort of thermonuclear
process has occurred with this white
dwarf but it clearly hasn't been quite
as destructive as it usually is because
there's still a white dwarf left at the
end and the other interesting thing is
that the nuclear processes haven't gone
all the way to the sort of end state
that they usually do usually you end up
producing you know so the the carbon in
the white dwarf ends up producing
silicon and the silicon turns into
nickel and the nickel turns into iron
there's a whole series of nuclear
reactions that go on and those produce
all the elements up to iron
the interesting thing about this white
dwarf is it doesn't have those heaviest
elements in it it doesn't have iron in
it it doesn't have nickel in it so it
looks like the process was sort of
incomplete it didn't destroy the star
and it didn't go through all the nuclear
reactions that these things usually go
through so it's like a failed supernova
it didn't quite fail clearly something
pretty dramatic happened to it but it
didn't quite go all the way so it's sort
of yeah it didn't quite detonate
completely it was an incomplete
detonation the other interesting thing
about it this particular star is they
can measure its speed you can measure
the doppler shift to tell you it's speed
along the line of sight but actually
there are also proper motion
measurements for it they're also
measurements of its its changing
position on the sky so they know how
fast it's going and it's actually it's
going around the wrong way it's not
orbiting around the milky way in the
same direction as most stars are and on
top of that it's going at about 200
kilometers per second so it's click
it's going along at a pretty rapid rate
which suggests that whatever the
explosion process was
gave it a pretty big kick so it's now
traveling at high speed this again is a
sign of something to do with probably
the fact that it was in a binary system
to start with it'd be nice to think that
you know it was just some failed
explosion that kicked it enormously but
it turns out that that probably isn't
enough to give it the speed that we see
but what is enough to give it the speed
we see is if it was in a binary system
and the explosion was sufficient to
unbind the binary so that the two binary
stars were no longer bound to each other
because if for example this was a white
dwarf that was orbiting another white
dwarf they can get very close together
which means they're actually traveling
around each other at hundreds of
kilometers per second
and so if you then suddenly take one of
these white dwarves away the remaining
one will then just keep traveling at
that several hundred kilometers per
second
so it looks like it was probably in a
very tight binary probably with another
white dwarf star this incomplete
explosion occurred
because it ripped enough of the material
from the other white dwarf to create a
partial explosion
and that disrupted the the second star
probably almost completely and so this
first star then shot out
into the milky way but the one that's
shot out is the one that underwent the
supernova of sorts yes yeah the other
one was probably it might have been
destroyed completely in the explosion
just because it got caught in the blast
or it might still exist it might itself
also be flying off in some other
direction
um there's really no way of telling so
we haven't we don't know where the other
like the brother is
no clue at all so the one that's firing
off that we do know about the one that's
firing off into the depths of space
it's not just the recoil from the
explosion it's to do with the kind of
uncoupling from the gravitational
interaction
exactly it's almost certainly to do with
the fact that what we're most of the
speed we're seeing is the speed that it
originally had in its binary system but
suddenly that binary doesn't exist as a
binary anymore so it's just flying out
into space so there's a couple of
interesting implications of this one is
that this type of explosion so the
reason why we typically see supernovae
isn't because of the original explosion
it's because those explosions produce
lots of radioactive material which then
subsequently decays and over the weeks
and months that follow we see the energy
that's being released from those nuclear
decay products
the main nuclear decay product in type
1a supernovae is nickel
and of course this one never got around
to making any nickel so it wouldn't have
had any material to go through this
decay process which means that if we had
been around when the supernova occurred
it probably almost certainly worked it
would have been in the very distant past
but if such supernovae do go off you
probably wouldn't see them because
unless you happen to be looking at just
the right moment when the flash occurred
then you wouldn't see it and then there
isn't that then slow subsequent decay
that would allow you to catch the
explosion
later on
the second sort of slight warning here
is this you know the the simple story we
usually tell about type 1a supernovae is
they're all the same and it's very
straightforward and that's why we can
use them as standard candles there is at
least a little bit of a warning here
that says actually sometimes weird
things happen and you get incomplete
explosions or different kinds of
explosions so it doesn't mean we have to
be a little careful if we're going to be
using type 1a supernovae as standard
candles mike you refer to this remnant
that's barreling through the milky way
as a star is it still acting like a star
is it is it undergoing nuclear processes
and emitting light and i mean it's still
emitting light because it's still hot
but it's a it is it's still a white
dwarf star so it's still held up by its
degeneracy pressure it's not got any new
nuclear processes going on in it so it's
a question whether you count white
dwarfs or stars or not if you think a
white dwarf's a star then this thing's
still a star if you think it's just the
remnant of a star then i guess at this
point it's just the remnant of the star
mike if this is a common process and
this happens a lot would we have seen
them before now like should we consider
this an oddity or is it possible these
things are everywhere
i mean they are relatively faint so
maybe we don't find you know we don't
find all of them necessarily and maybe
we haven't studied all stars in
sufficient detail but i think what this
is probably telling us is this this is a
kind of a rare process and if the story
i've told you is right that it
originated in a pair of white dwarves
that was sufficiently close to each
other that one was actually ripping
material from the other and at some
point one of them underwent a kind of
slightly failed explosion it's probably
a fairly unlikely scenario so i suspect
there's probably not a huge number of
them out there but we really don't know
at this point it sounds quite exciting
though doesn't it the idea of this of a
white dwarf like you know barreling
through the milky way on this sort of
cannonball run
and sort of running from the scene of
the crime as well actually right it's
clearly you know that it's just survived
this massive explosion and is now
heading off as fast as it can did this
finding excite you like do these things
still surprise you absolutely in fact so
you know so in fact you told me about
this paper i didn't know about this
paper at least you pointed me towards a
newspaper article about it uh which got
me to read the paper uh it's not why you
know i usually do galaxies i don't do
white dwarfs and supernovae and things
but
the more i read about in the paper the
more interesting i got in it because
it's clear this is a very intriguing
object
[Music]
if star clusters
or if they were galaxies and if there
are galaxies then that's something
really really interesting because it's
not clear how such a
dense galaxy could form which is really
really quite nice it's not a very
impressive image but this is the first
image that new horizons took before it
went on to take images of jupiter when
it flew past jupiter and then images of
pluto and now even images of an asteroid
in the kuiper belt as well